But right now,
with a few
notable exceptions who deserve c
Most Republican politicians,
they're not even
pretending that the rules apply
They seem to be willing
to just make stuff up
And that's true here in Nevada,
just like it is across the count
As the co-chair
of Donald Trump's
campaign in Nevada, Katherine's
helped to lead efforts to overtu
the results of the last election
But don't vote. What am I?
What are we going to do?
We don't vote
Buddy Buddy filed bogus lawsuits
push phony claims of voter fraud
So so I think it's fair to say
that if he loses this race,
he's going to do it again.
He has no actual evidence
of election fraud
because
there's actually no widespread
election fraud.
But he's not going to let that s
He's going to look
under every rock in the desert
to try to find an excuse.
Although if he wins, I'm guessin
he'll be less concerned
All those votes will be legit.
Funny how that works.
Listen,
I lost my first congressional ra
about 30 points I got looked
you know, you know what I did no
I didn't say this was rigged.
I didn't play in front.
I certainly didn't instigate
a riot on the Capitol
Instead, I asked myself,
how can I be better?
How can I connect with voters be
Because that's how it's supposed
to work.
That that's stuff
we teach our kids right
You know, you're in the sandbox.
Things don't go your way.
You don't throw a tantrum,
throw something that the other k
If the
if you
if you see your kid
do that, you pull him aside.
Kind of hard to get on. So I
listen
I don't do that.
We teach our kids to be fair.
To be honest,
we should expect the same
from our politicians.
Because, listen,
I understand that democracy
might not seem like a top priori
right now,
especially when it doesn't
always feel like
the results work for you.
You don't see enough progress
on issues that matter to you
and your family.
Sometimes progress is slow,
but we have seen
throughout history
and we see right now around the
what happens
when you give up on democracy.
You can see it in countries
where the government tells you w
you can and cannot read.
Countries where if you dissent,
you get
put in the jail, countries
where reporters
are silenced.
In countries where it doesn't
matter who you vote for
because the same folks
are going to win every time
and they'll do whatever they wan
And where corruption is rampant
because there's no accountabilit
When true democracy goes
away, people get hurt
and it's hard to recover.
It has real life consequences.
And that's why
generations of Americans
fought and died
for the idea of self-government.
That's what
this flag is supposed to stand f
That's why we believe and set up
and democratic norms that work r
we teach our kids
when they're little about being
and being fair,
about how groups
are supposed to make decisions.
And everybody gets the same
and everybody gets a turn.
And if you don't get your way,
you don't take your ball and go
or have a tantrum.
You get over and try to
do better the next time
Democracy is at stake
in this election in Nevada.
And that's why it's not enough
to elect Democrats like Steve
Sims like and Catherine Cortez M
We also have to elect good peopl
up and down the ballot,
like Cisco Aguilar,
who's running
to be your secretary of state
You know,
Nevada makes it easier to vote i
than the many other states.
You got early voting.
You got universal mail in voting
same day voter registration.
They don't just help Democrats.
They make it easier
for everybody to cast their ball
no matter who you're voting for.
Cisco's opponent wants to make i
to vote.
He's trying to one up all the Re
peddling lies about the 2020 ele
by saying that all elections in
for the
last 15 years have been fake.
Really?
The last 15 years, all of
these going around
rural Nevada, spreading lies
about how you can't trust
you like electronic voting machi
But apparently you can't trust
an election denier to oversee vo
hand counting ballots.
That's not somebody
you want in charge of your elect
It'd be like
if the Raiders
were playing the Chiefs then,
and you noticed that instead of
who've been calling games for 20
somebody said, Hey,
how about that guy
over there wearing the Chiefs ge
who's been
tailgating for the last 3 hours,
drinking some brews
and ranting about that,
how the Chiefs
actually beat
the Bucs in the Super Bowl last
They look impartial.
Let let's put them in charge.
If you want to do that for
a football game,
why would you do it for an elect
Instead, what you need to do
is vote for somebody
like Cisco who believes
that every vote should count.
Full stop shouldn't be a radical
It can used to be a radical idea
That's why you've got to send Ci
to the secretary of state's offi
to protect the integrity
of our elections.
Make sure your voters can
Right now
you get a chance to make a diffe
So long as you vote
and we joke in my house
between me and Michelle, Michel
sometimes be the glass half empt
She goes, she can get a little d
and the hope and change guy.
So I'm usually a little more opt
and sometimes when she
gets down
about the state of the country,
state of the world,
she's been reading too much,
watching too much stuff
here and crazy stuff.
I say Hey, honey, it's going to
because I believe it will be.
But you know what?
It won't be okay on its own.
The reason I believe will be oka
is because I believe in you.
It'll be okay if we fight for it
and work for it,
not just on Election Day,
but every day in between.
That's why this election matters
Nevada
These may be tough times, but
we've been through tough times b
We just have to resist the tempt
to give up.
To turn inward,
to see politics is a zero sum ga
where on every
everything goes and rules are br
And the only way
people like, quote
unquote us win
is if people like them lose.
Remember what I said at the begi
that is how we
lose when we turn on each other
and make up stuff about each oth
But if we come together
then I'm optimistic
because even in our darkest mome
and there have been darker momen
in this country before
We've always had more in common
than our politics.
And sometimes our politicians su
even when times are tough.
What unites us
Family.
Community.
Respect.
Dignity.
Hard work. Honesty.
What unites us
has always been stronger
than what divides.
There have been certain values
that bind us together as citizen
No matter who we are,
no matter where we come from.
No matter what we look like.
No matter who we love.
That's the promise of America.
That's what this stands for.
That's who we are.
And in
this election, you
have a chance to vote
for leaders like Steven Horsford
and Dina Titus
and Susie Lee and Adam
Ford and Cisco
Aguilar
and Steve Sisolak
and Catherine Cortez Masto, who
in that flag and believe in thos
And we'll fight for the big incl
hopeful, forward
looking America that we all beli
We may not fix
all our problems overnight,
but we can make things better.
And that is worth fighting for.
So if you're anxious or frustrat
right now, don't complain.
Don't tune out.
Go get bamboozled.
Don't fall for the okey doke.
Get off your coat.
Get, get get off your couch.
And do what?
Put down your phones and do what
Vote for this thing.
Incredible. Nevada Democratic ti
Make sure other folks do the sam
If enough of us make our voices
we will build a country that is
and more
just and more equal and more fre
I believe in you.
Let's go do it.
Thank you. Las Vegas.